In this section of our tutorial I'd like to talk about the editor UI and go over how we
navigate through the editor as well as how we play and what some of the various menus
do.
Now the editor itself is going to be broken down in kind of the six major areas.
So one we have our file menu bar.
This is going to be the same throughout a lot of editors that you see inside of Unreal
Engine 5.
Two, we have our main toolbar.
This goes across the top here.
Three is our editor viewport.
So we're going to be spending a lot of our time.
Four is the tabbed drawer system.
Five is our content browser.
And then six here, this is going to be our output log and some things for notifications
for save.
So take a look at each one of these areas in more depth in the editor because it's
kind of important to understand what each one does.
So again, across the top here we have our file, edit, window tools, build selected,
actors and help.
So file is going to allow us to access anything that's related to opening or saving a level
as well as opening up our projects or even zipping up our projects right here should
be want to share them.
It is going to do anything that we have revolving or I should say involving, undo as well as
our editor preferences and our project settings and plugins.
So these are important settings right down here.
If we ever want to edit any preferences for our editor or a project or disable or enable
any plugins, we can access those options right here.
Window allows us to access the various level editor windows and other tools that we might
want to work with.
The cool thing about this is we can open up multiple content browsers or detail panels.
We can also activate things like our layers or our levels or our light mixer should we
want to do that.
One of the other super useful features of the windows tab is this load layout.
You can use this in case you accidentally loaded something inside of Unreal and you weren't
sure you want to kind of go back.
This is a great way to just quickly get your UI back to its default state.
Now tools allows us to view various tools that we can use to help us do everything from
say merge actors to audit our assets and even set up our device managers and our profiles.
We can also run Python scripts and convert levels to world partition through this menu.
Build allows us to build either everything by clicking on the build all levels up here
at the top or it allows us to just build these individual things here.
We're going to build things like our reflection or pre-computed static visibility.
If we're using HLODs we can build those from this particular menu, landscape and texture
streaming all types of other things can all be done from the build level right here.
Select has to deal with selection.
If I have something selected here and I come to select you can see here I can get a few
options so I can select all.
I'm going to hold down L and click really quick and I'm going to click select again
and you can see here I get some slightly different settings so I can select all relevant lights
or select all lights or select all stationary lights that exceed overlap.
There's a lot of interesting things I can do here with select.
Now actor is going to be context sensitive.
That means that if I don't have anything selected actor is not going to show any information
and with that actor selected it's going to allow me to do a bunch of different things
with this particular actor that I have selected such as I can convert this, I could replace
it with another asset.
There's a ton of things that I can do here including grouping and changing it to pivot
or attaching it and then last but not least we have help.
Help is where we're going to view all of the various help so from our viewport controls
and level documentation to API references to credits and even our bout or visit you
can find everything that you need for help here in our help menu.
Alright so two is going to be our main toolbar so that's going to cover this area that is
right here so this is going to be our save current level to disk.
Now this doesn't save everything this just saves the current level this browses to the
current level that's on disk.
Selection mode changes the editor's tool set to respect the different thing that you have
selected here and we'll cover these tools later on in this in more detail but note for
now that selection mode is how we can access some further tools inside of Unreal Engine
5.
Next to that we have quickly add to the project what this does is this allows us to quickly
add things such as lights or shapes or cinematic things to our project that we might need to
work with.
Next to that we have our blueprint this allows us to either add blueprints or open and edit
our level blueprint we can also modify our game blueprint and our game mode override here
should be need to from this menu.
Next to that we have our cinematics cinematics I should say it's called by another name which
is sequencer so if I open this up you can see here I can add a level sequence or add
a level sequence for the shots should I need to use that.
Next to this we have our PIE or play in editor control so if I just click play right now
it's going to plop me right there but if I click these little ellipses right here you
can see I have a bunch of different options.
Now the great thing about this is that not only can I simulate or play this game either
in a new viewport or in a standalone game I can also simulate multiplayer by adding
the number of players down here and adjusting the settings I want for multiplayer.
Next to that we have platforms what this does is this allows us to quickly launch our project
on the various platforms that is selected so for example if we're coming down here to
Android we would pick package project and then we'd be able to run that from our Android
devices if we had an Android device plugged in and ready we'd see it right up here at
the top and we could just select it as well to quickly launch on it.
Now the last setting up here is settings and what this settings does is there are some
settings here for things like translucent selection but the main usage of this is going
to be for your scalability for our material quality levels and our preview platform overrides.
These allow us to adjust the visual settings of Unreal Engine 5's editor window right here
so that we can get a better idea of what the project is going to look like on say reduced
settings or limited hardware.
Alright so three is our viewport.
This is where you're going to spend 99% of your time inside of Unreal Engine 5.
This is because the viewport is where we add objects but we also manipulate them, move
them around, duplicate them and things of that nature in order to bring us the creations
that you are building with Unreal Engine 5 and you can see here I'm just kind of navigating
around the viewport.
There are a few options across the top here at the viewport.
On the left hand side we have some options for our viewport then we have the ability
to change our camera.
We have the ability to look at various lighting modes and then we have show which will show
us various flags and options such as rendering sprites like this player start or this point
light.
Going a little bit further down here we have our select, move, rotate and scale as well
as controls to control the snapping and this last little button right here this controls
our maximize and minimizes the viewport here.
Now next to that we have our outliner and our details panel.
These are Unreal's tab drawer system and the reason I want to bring that up is these can
be just brought up and kind of docked together like that so you're not stuck with this particular
menu but these two outliners and details panels are very important to understand what they
do.
So the outliner will outline all of the objects or actors that we have placed inside of our
scene so it's going to show us this and this and this and whatever I have currently selected
the outliner is going to show us that we can also select things inside of the outliner.
Now the details panel that is going to show us the details or the properties of the actor
that we have selected so you can see here when I select a player start I can come down
here and I have a transformation and object and a rendering but when I select a light
you'll notice I have a transformation but I have a light now instead of the other properties
that I had when I had the player start so there we go.
So you can see here the outliner again allows us to look at objects or actors that have
been placed inside of our scene and then the details panel allows us to get more information
or edit its properties.
So next we have the content drawer so this is really simply just allows us to access
the content browser you can also access this by hitting control space on the keyboard and
if you like you can press this dock in layout to have that dock right there in the layout
for you so that it is constantly up so you can search with it.
Finally we have our output log our command section and what this does is this just allows
us to look at our log should we need to use this for any debug information our CMD here
this allows us to input either commands or Python commands that we need to activate inside
of the editor.
Trace allows us to run memory traces and this is used for advanced debugging on your projects
you need to figure out why your project is performing poorly.
Our derived data cache is used when we are working on a team of multiple people and we
want to have our data load a little more quickly we can use this to help in our data loading.
We then have our map status which is showing us currently this map is unsaved and then
we have our version control or revision control that shows us if we are working with some
form of version control what we are connected to and what changes are currently being applied
or what changes we currently need to make.
That represents the Unreal Engine kind of editor UI.
Now as I was going in the editor I was moving around and to do that there are actually two
different ways we can go about this.
We can use the WAS and D keys and the left or right mouse button so we can use the WAS
and D to move us around or we can use the right mouse button to and this would be commonly
referred to as first person controls so it is pretty standard across multiple first person
shooter games where we use WAS and D to move our carat forward backwards left and right.
There is another way that we can move throughout the editor we can hold down the right mouse
button to drag around the scene from a static POV or we can hold down the middle mouse button
to track up down left and right.
Let's just take a look at that again so again we hold down the left mouse button and we
can go like this hold down the right mouse button and we can move we hold them both together
and we can move left and right and we hold down the middle mouse button we can also move
up and down.
One of the things that I like to do is just kind of mess with the WAS and D until I get
to something and then I use the individual mouse buttons to help kind of focus in what
it is that I happen to try to be looking at.
We can also use Q and E to raise the camera up and down.
Z and C will temporarily allow us to increase or decrease our field of view so we can kind
of get a zoom in effect there or see our project in extreme distortion.
If you hold down ALT with something selected you will get an orbit style and you can also
use the middle mouse button to move your camera around similar to how you would do the camera
inside of something like 3D Studio Max or Maya.
Finally if you press the F key this will focus you into something so let's say that maybe
you got super zoomed out or something like that you can just simply grab something and
hit the F key to focus right in on it.
Now when we are editing objects we have the ability to move, rotate and scale them and
each one of those functionalities is going to be notified by a specific gizmo.
The move gizmo looks like this, our rotation gizmo shows us different axes that we can
rotate and our scale looks similar to our move but instead of showing arrows it has these
little handles we can pull to scale in our relative directions.
Each one of our select transform, rotate and scale has some options as well as the ability
to snap to a grid.
The reason we want to snap to a grid is this helps us move things in certain increments
so we can move this every 10 units or we can rotate this every 10 degrees or we can snap
this every .25 in scale and this really helps when we are trying to maybe move something
or scale something in a very precise increments.
Let's pop over to the editor and look at that now.
So first off I'm just going to grab this ball right here and I'm going to hit F to focus
in on it and then I'm just going to hit the space bar to cycle through my various widgets
and then once I have a widget I want I can again just grab on that axis to do the rotation
or the move or I should say the rotation and the scale.
There we go, set it backwards.
Then I want.
Now if I don't want any of that I can come here and actually do this and you'll see here
that I have a lot more finer control over how I am doing this scaling operation or if
I was to come here to my, let's just turn it off for everything.
You can see here now I can move this over ever so slightly as with the grid on I have a little
bit of a snapping on there and the same thing with our rotation.
I can rotate this ever so slightly.
You can even see that reflected in the degree operation there that you're seeing at the
top of my gizmo it's showing me that I'm going at 14.8, 16 and if I turn this back on we
will see that going at every 10 degree increments.
Now the last thing that I do want to talk about is a little bit more on PIE because there are
some other things that we can do with this.
So again PIE stands for play in editor and it can be used to play literally right from the area
you are navigating.
You can also use alt PIE on your keyboard to set this as a shortcut and we use this for a lot of things.
Let me just pop over to the editor really quick.
So first and foremost right click play from here.
This is going to be something to use a lot of times and this is really great because it basically
launches you from the area that you clicked on.
So it's going to right click, it's going to select that pixel over there and basically put me as close to that pixel as I can.
The reason this is so good is if I was to hit play, play is always going to start me from over here.
So let's say that I am trying to look at something over here that I'm investigating or something like that.
When I hit play I'm going to go all the way over here in order to get there.
So that's why this right click play from here is so powerful because it allows me to play right from an area that I need to get to to get information.
One of the other things that you can do is we drop down this arrow, there's going to be this simulate.
So what simulate does is it runs the game but it doesn't add the player.
So this is really good if we are trying to debug something and we want the game to run but we don't necessarily need the game to give us a player.
So we can use simulate to simulate things like the physics thread and once we've done that we can then stop and then do that one more time to run without having to actually get out of the player or navigate to another location.
Simulate makes it really really easy to do this right inside of the editor viewport.
So again, Alt S is to simulate and we'll hit escape to stop that and then Alt P is to play the actual game.
And these are going to really help you out especially once you have been play testing or you need to test something throughout further interaction you're going to find that this is a really great way to do that.